uh yeah welcome everyone great to see so
many people i'm glad you made it so
early in the morning i had trouble
myself but uh glad we're all here uh
this is actually the first time i'm
giving this tutorial in person so i'm
very excited
it's also kind of new so let's see how
it goes
yeah actually before we get started i'm
curious
to get a bit of a sense of the room and
adjust its tutorial so you all get the
most out of it
who already knows about dusk
okay who has used it
okay great
who uses pi data libraries like pandas
numpy
scikit learn
okay great
who uses spark
great
uh
and who has experience with distributed
computing
okay excellent great that really uh that
that helps me um and yeah like vincent
says already feel free i mean i would
love for this to be a very interactive
tutorial
so interrupt me um ask questions
i'm here to
hopefully uh give you 90 minutes that'll
be worth your time so feel free to give
me feedback and ask questions as we go
along uh that'll only make it better for
for everyone here
um yeah so vince had already said my
name is richard pogram i'm a developer
advocate at coiled
coiled is the company built by matt
rocklin around
desk
i have a background in design and
communication sciences and my specific
interests are kind of looking at data
tooling the modern data stack
doing
arabic and natural language processing
and when i'm not doing serious things
like that i like to ferment just about
anything in my path so if you're making
miso or kimchi or kombucha
come talk to me and we can exchange
recipes
cool in the next 90 minutes um we'll
start by building some intuition and
motivation around what dasc is and what
you can use it for i'll go through this
pretty quick uh
especially given uh who's in the room
but if you have questions or if i'm
going too fast uh feel free to stop me
and we can pause
after that we'll have about an hour
maybe a bit more to work through uh the
notebooks that i've prepared um
to yeah get get hands-on with with using
disk for different use cases
and then in the end we'll have about 20
minutes depending on how the coding goes
for q a but i'm also very happy to do
that q a as we code so basically the
last you know the bulk of this section
will be will be interactive coding
all right so we'll cover kind of what is
dusk then look at how we can use it and
we'll end with any questions that that
you might have
cool
what is dasc uh dasc is a python library
that scales uh pi data libraries like
pandas numpy scikit learn xgboost for
distributed computing
so who here of you has used pandas or
numpy and run into memory errors
you're all in the right place this is
great
um
right so dusk allows you to process
more data
in less time
and allows you to process more data than
you can fit in your
machine's ram
yeah so dusk scales python but why would
we want to scale python uh with that uh
i'd like to welcome you to this year's
uh nascar races uh quick little uh
analogy to build some intuition uh so
this is the pandas race car i think a
lot of you here in this room are
familiar with it it's great it does what
it uh it's popular uh it's got good
performance for
relatively small data sets right and
small as a subjective term
but um i think the rule of thumb is you
need about five times the size of your
data set uh in ram in order to not to
run into memory errors so i've got 16
gigabytes of ram on this laptop
when i start processing data frames with
five or six gigabytes
worth of data
i'm likely to run into issues
so we can see that easily here if we
import the new york city taxicab data
we can import one month it's about one
gigabyte of data no problem but if we
try to import all of the data
at least on this machine i'll get a
memory error
and ask exists to solve this problem so
it was
created
when the limits of pi data libraries
like pandas and numpy scikit-learn
started to become visible
the size of data sets was increasing i
said okay
how can we
stick to the libraries that people love
pandas numpy psychic learn same syntax
these work great we just have to solve
for the scaling issue
um and that's how task was uh
it
sorry
uh yeah
i'll come back later yeah
um
yeah so
pandas is just one of those race cars in
these nascar races we have numpy socket
learn xgboost xray prefect
and really you can think of dasc as the
engine
that you can sort of put into
these race cars
to to scale them up for for larger data
sets so it's the same car just gets a
different engine it's a familiar feel
the same api
um
you can use the same pandas methods
uh that that that you are used to and
familiar with but you don't have any
more limits on the data size you can
process
so then a pandas
race car with a desk engine becomes a
das data frame we'll dig into more
detail later what that looks like
but basically pandas is limited because
it's running on a single core
and ask
will take a large das data frame cut
that up into smaller pandas data frames
and each band's data frame will be
processed
on a separate core in parallel
it's great you know if you're scaling up
to all the cores in your machine
it can be even greater if you scale up
to multiple
workers in a cluster
and you know scale up potentially
infinitely
so
that does that with pandas to give you
the pandas data frame it also does it
with
numpy to give you a dask array
scikit learn to give you desk ml
xg boost
and so on
um
that's great if you are using pandas
numpy scikit-learn
but the great thing about desk is that
it also
offers a lower level api uh called das
delayed and das futures uh which allows
you to scale any
arbitrary python function for
distributed computing
so in this sort of hands-on coding
tutorial part of the tutorial later on
uh we'll look at how to do this as well
um you may have seen some of these uh
visuals on our coiled booth already this
is the das dashboard which gives you
live
visual
information about computations that are
running on your cluster um
and we'll we'll see more of that live
and and and this kind of um
lower level flexibility is also a a
great selling point for dusk as opposed
to kind of more traditional mapreduce
systems because it gives you a lot more
flexibility in building your own task
graph
and and creating custom parallel
computations
so very quickly just the summary for
this intuition stage of the tutorial das
is an engine for high performance
parallel computing
you can step right into sort of
pre-built race cars right that's the
pandas numpy xgboost but then with the
desk engine um
or you can build your own very uh
your own custom task graphs uh for for
custom parallel python code
all right so
how does work and why does it matter
before we get into the hands-on just
want to run through kind of a a real
world case study to demonstrate a use
case of desk in the financial services
industry
so das is quite popular for processing
time series data at scale
that's one of the many uses of task
this is a case study
from one of the coiled
clients capital one
um
we will have a center for machine
learning uh you can imagine capital one
one of the biggest u.s banks they have
quite a bit of data lying around they
want to make use of it they're in a
competitive environment
and they have a large organization and
so they're quite fragmented in how they
are
spitting up
their resources and crunching the data
and so they have a need for a simple and
repeatable way to stand up large
infrastructure they want to leverage
gpus
and sort of centralize efforts across
the
organization
basically they want to process more data
in less time
they also have uh um sort of an a
challenge with uh different programming
languages in their organization so
there's a lot of python
programmers who like to code in python
but then need to use
something like pi spark when they want
to scale
um and then there's other you know
there's other people using other things
and they basically um
are a big fan of python and wanted to
stay python native
but needed a flexible and robust way to
do that
so
they
work with lots of data as i said
this is an example of one of their
machine learning pipelines
kind of a schematic they'll sample some
data do some feature engineering
merge a few tables train and then score
they were running this
as part of an airflow orchestrated model
on a 40 gigabyte training data set
it was taking about two and a half hours
training per ensemble and two and a half
weeks for the whole pipeline
but the 40 gigabytes is not all of their
data this is just the sub
subset i think
uh something around five percent
and this approach was not very scalable
you can imagine if five percent is
taking
you know multiple weeks then you'll
probably never get around to doing the
hundred percent especially in a
fast-paced business environment
so they did some initial scaling with
dusk using dask data frame so this is
the scaled version of pandas data frames
to parallelize at first just the
sampling portion of the pipeline they
were using 80 dash workers so a cluster
with a total of almost 700 gigabytes of
distributed memory
and they were able to process this in 15
hours instead of two and a half weeks
which is a significant
speed up which
they were now able to process the entire
one terabyte data set in in seven days
which is still a long time but it's uh
a good speed up
uh which meant
at least for for the testing they could
do daily iteration instead of weekly and
you can imagine that that's uh speed
speeds up things across the organization
from there
they were uh
pretty impressed and pleased with what
das could do so they used das in in
other parts of the pipeline as well
i'm going to run through this pretty
quick so we can just focus on doing some
coding but wanted to give you a sense of
of uh kind of applications of desk in
in in real world scenarios
das also works well with rapids so if
you have access to gpus
that's another way
that capital one
increased their or reduced their their
training cost and time
for this specific instance
um yeah there's a source here uh to the
uh the full talk if you're interested i
think it's about 30 minutes um yeah that
uh it's a great resource but basically
this is an instance of of desk task
scaling up
the data processing and the company
finally being able to use all of their
data which was sitting around
all right i think with that
um
yeah we'll come to that later i think
we're gonna dive into the um
tutorial right now
uh i mentioned it already for those of
you who came in a little early this is
the
link that will take you to the github
repo for this tutorial
in the github repo you will find two
ways
to set up your machine to follow along
one is to launch
a binder notebook
and
the other is to clone the repository
um is the binder notebook working for
everyone who's using it yeah
excellent
all right um let me pause for questions
here before we dive into the code
any questions
yes
sure
so on oh yeah
is there a situation where not used for
example i don't know
working with small data sets and the
overhead is so large that actually it
runs faster on panels
yeah great question uh
so for everyone in the back also the
question is is there a situation when
you should not use das for example if
the data set is uh small enough for
pandas to use it that's exactly right
and that that's
basically for well
if you have a
but the use case for desk is clear right
if you run into memory issues if you're
not running into memory issues uh it's
hard to say sort of blanket statement of
what will happen uh das will still let
you
if you're working locally scale out to
all of your cores
uh which could be a performance speed up
uh there's also an overhead involved so
if you um yeah basically our advice and
and the other thing is working with task
means you're entering the world of
distributed computing which is
complicated things uh get complex so our
advice generally is if pandas is working
for you and you're happy with how
quickly it's running use pandas don't
switch over to desk
um but yeah does that does that answer
your question yeah so um patricia a
remote attendee asked um is it possible
to use dax in combination with um celery
which split stacks across several celery
workers
uh i'm not very familiar with salary
myself but i
think so
no
okay
let's say i have a python package
that makes use of pandas data frames and
panda series can i
use this also with dusk can i say run
this pandas code with and scale it with
task
uh i yeah i mean so under the hood dusk
is cutting up your data if you're using
dash data frame it's cutting it up into
pandas data frames and then mapping
functions over those
so i suppose it'll take a little rewrite
somewhere um but technically if if your
uh library is acting on on panel's data
frames there should be a way to to map
that uh function um
using task
all right
let's uh jump into some code
so in the repo there are
six notebooks
i think we will focus on the first four
or five uh for this session and let's
see how we go
um
we will cover um basically the first
notebook is really kind of just just a
test drive very quick uh run through the
different functions of desk and then the
following notebooks are diving into more
detail of each section
we'll talk about das data frames so
that's the the scaled up version of
pandas task arrays the scaled-up version
of numpy we'll talk about machine
learning with task
which scales up scikit-learn and xgboost
and then the fifth notebook is
talking about das delayed which is the
api for
scaling custom
or arbitrary python functions
that that sort of fall outside
those those apis
let's see maybe
can everyone in the back read
the text on the screen yeah great thanks
all right um so
let's
this is kind of the a quick test drive
um
first of the das data frame so this is
the api that scales pandas uh instead of
importing pandas you would import dask
data frame as dd
um we'll run a real little script here
to to download uh some
flight data
and then we can use dd dot read csv very
familiar syntax
to import that data set
we can inspect the first
five rows with head
as you would expect with pandas
and we can
run a group by computation
and who can tell me what's different
between this
and pandas code
does anyone spot the difference
yeah the compute at the end
so
that's
a slight different difference with
pandas
which is quite fundamental in a way to
to understand how distributed computing
works uh right the whole thing we're
trying to do here is process uh memory
uh sorry process data sets that are
larger than our local memory so we have
to find a way to we can't load it all
into memory at once that's why we use
something called lazy evaluation
which means that dask builds a task
graph is the technical term you could
see it as a route map or a recipe for
how to get to your result
but it will not execute that result
until you specifically tell it to and
the command to tell it to get you the
result is compute
this means
um
yeah for so this this is uh
a
sample data set that's relatively small
so technically we could we could load it
all in but if this would be a 100
gigabyte data frame and we would just
call compute we would run out of out of
memory
a group i is an aggregation so the
result of that will likely be much
smaller and that's something you could
compute
and load into memory
this is why if you just call df in
pandas you would get contents of the
data frame here
but dask
is
does not do that because
usually your data set won't fit into
memory so you would run into a memory
error if you just called the data frame
instead what does provides is some
schematic information
yep
um
that's the wrong clone link sorry about
that um
sorry about that okay um
let me see
you should be cloning
so this link is incorrect that's right
that's uh that's my bad so you could
clone it from here it's probably the
best thing to do
all right um
yeah so what what what dask uh does give
you when you call the data frame is some
schematic information uh about the data
frame itself which are the column names
uh the
data types of the columns
dasc does not read all of the
data again because it might not fit into
memory so it will infer the data types
by reading a certain number of
first columns
this
is something to pay attention to because
your data types might change or you
might have a
a
an issue with with data types in a
column that hasn't been read
so the sort of the fail-safe way
to do that is to
specify your data types uh
ahead of time
when you when you load the data in
and uh it will also give you something
called number of partitions so this is
the number of chunks or partitions that
dask has cut your big data set into
and each of these partitions is actually
a pandas data frame that is processed in
parallel
[Music]
so we'll they get into this some more uh
in the next notebook uh but let's move
on to what das arrays can do
so here we would import das array asda
we can create
an array
of ten thousand by ten thousand
with uh random integers um and again
just like with the data frame
we don't get any uh results or contents
when we call the array
we simply get some
schematic information
about the number of chunks the size of
the whole array
and then we can
again we can slice
index slice this array
won't get results until you specifically
call compute
quick demonstration of doing machine
learning with task
there's a
separate library called das ml which
mimics the scikit-learn
interface
we can make a classification problem
with synthetic data
this will produce
a desk arrays
and we can then fit
a logistic regression model
inputting those dask arrays so this look
should all look pretty familiar if you
use scikit-learn
again the main difference here is
calling compute
when you want results yes
of scikit-learn yeah uh scikit-learn is
i would say i mean i'm hesitant to give
an exact percentage but it's not
everything no so um
das ml
scales if i'm not mistaken all the
algorithms that have an n jobs
keyword argument because not every
algorithm can be
parallelized
um and then for xgboost there's a
separate uh integration uh that's native
native to axiboose which we'll we'll
also look at uh so but for psychic learn
out of out of the pandas numpy socket
learn psychic learn the least supported
i'd say pandas is about 80 85 percent
numpy's the same and then psychic learn
uh it's just a few algorithms that that
can be easily paralyzed
does the
the typical sklearn support the um the
test data frame so can can we simply
pass a dust data frame into an sqlearn
uh that's a good question i
am not sure i also don't know why you
would want to do that because that is
not
parallel so
the reason then you would be incurring
overhead by using desk but they're not
getting the parallel gains
from from processing the the algorithm
in parallel so
so i have some online questions yeah i'm
so um the first one um you mentioned
rapids does it act as a sort of back end
for dax or if i remember correctly
does it have its own data frame api
or how is it interpretable
sorry the rapids does it act as its own
back end for the dax
or according to the question if i
remember correctly it has its own data
frame api
how does it work together
uh yeah i'm going to leave that question
for a little later this is quite
advanced i'd like to keep that then
how can it show entries for
dataframe.head
when it doesn't have the data frame in
memory
yeah so
dataframe.head calls compute under the
hood um so it will load it will look at
the first five or whatever you tell it
rows and load those into memory
does dax work on copy or view of the
pandas data frame
sorry does dax work on the copy
on a copy or view of the
pandas data frame ooh that's a good
question copy your view of the dancer
okay um
i'm not sure oh
and the last one sorry okay what kind of
cluster uses dax in the background for
dax ml
so
is dax ml only usable on a local machine
or
also on a compute cluster uh both yeah
so that's the i mean the great thing
about das is that the same code can run
on your laptop uh or on a cloud cluster
uh you'll just switch out the the um
the place where you run the computations
and that's something i'll show in a
minute yeah
all right
and then uh this is the lower level api
that i that i talked about uh briefly
already uh das delayed
uh which will allows you to parallelize
uh any python function uh so here kind
of very simple uh example
we will define a function increment
which will sleep for one one second then
return uh x plus one
uh define a function add which
adds x y and z and also takes one second
to run
if we run this normally um
sequentially each function takes one
second we're running three functions
uh this will take three seconds
and we will get a result
said
if we import das delayed uh we can use
it as a function decorator uh around our
functions
um
i've already shown you the uh the secret
here but um
this will run extremely fast
because it's not doing anything
uh so this is only building the task
graph uh saying okay if
and when i want to get this result
this is how i would get there
so it runs extremely fast but you also
don't have a result yet you only have a
delayed object that points
to a result that still needs to be
computed
we can visualize this so a is
the result result of the increment
function
being run once
b is the same
and c
this is where we start to build task
graphs
is the result final result of uh the add
function
being applied to the two results of the
increment function
someone take a guess how long
this will take to run when we actually
run it
anyone
two seconds i hear two seconds
yeah
um
thank god
2.01
so
the two increments functions are running
in parallel
i have eight cores in this laptop so i
could potentially on this laptop scale
up to eight increment functions uh and
and still get to the two seconds beyond
that uh things will have to wait um
because i only have eight cores
um
we could
trade change this function and then
we're running three increment functions
that will still take two seconds
so this is a very very kind of simple
example to to showcase what you can do
with das delayed uh but you can imagine
for for kind of more complex uh
situations
you can build your own task graphs and
and the great thing about this really is
is that um you know pandas numpy
scikit-learn these these are all great
but there are abstractions and your data
doesn't always fit neatly into a das
data frame when you get it
um
and and this is a great way to kind of
uh work around some of those uh rougher
edges
um to answer the question about uh
uh whether das works locally or on the
cluster
uh the answer is both and this is where
coiled comes in this is the the company
that that i work for
um we provide a very uh
smooth way to uh scale up skill desk up
to clusters in the cloud so you can
import coiled
and spin up a
you'll need a coiled account to to do
this
but you can spin up a
coiled cluster in the cloud in this case
specifying 20 workers each with 25
gigabytes of ram
uh
coiled will distribute a software
environment to all of your workers in
that cluster to make sure they have the
right python dependencies
and then all the code we've just run uh
no changes i mean what we connect dask
to the cluster with
this client object and then from there
all the code will run
in the cloud
so this is really uh great for
you know doing local development uh at
home on your laptop um and then whenever
you need to uh scale to production or
have
want to work with a full data set
and need to speed up you can scale to
the cloud
um
let's just
demonstrate that quickly so
i've already spun this cluster up uh
ahead of time but this is where
this is the coiled interface you can see
we have a cluster with a name that's
running with 20 workers
it's running in aws we also support gcp
and azure is coming as well
we're running spot instances in this
case
and we can run a computation on this
cluster
we import the data frame
read in this case all of the new york
city taxi data
as expected just calling the das data
frame only gives us the schematic
but when we run a group by on this data
set
this is now running in the cloud
and
das gives you a nice dashboard
to keep track of your computation so you
can see the tasks that are running
on all of our 20 workers
you can see the the memory stored in
each worker
the progress that's going on
and there's a lot more information in
this dashboard
to look at
we like this dashboard so much that we
make t-shirts with it so
it's famous
all right that's just a very quick run
through of everything that we'll cover
uh in more detail right now
any questions
before we continue yeah so now that you
show this complex i was having my
experience with firespark problems with
complex
lazy evaluation when you have
the graph task is increasing or the
valuation plan increases a lot yeah in
iterative process
usually they they crash
so let's dash avoid this because you
have i see that you have only actions
like a compute the versus
transformations not evaluations
when you have alternative processes
that's anyhow avoiding to have
very complex or huge graphs that crash
at the end yeah so
i don't know
my colleague guido yesterday gave a talk
about active memory management in dusk
uh so the das scheduler makes very
is built to to make uh to optimize these
computations and avoid crashes like this
so that's something that's continuously
in development um
yeah
the scheduler should take care of that
um and if it doesn't then uh let us know
and we'll we'll make it better
which is something different um of
course for parallelizing tasks but if
the data set is
huge improvement due to parallelization
that
too
is lost because of pickles
um i'm not sure
that's
the answer
there you go
a question here uh so the if i
understand when when we are in local uh
uh like without the cluster
then what we are essentially doing is is
to avoid the guild right
we are just
using multi-processing to to avoid
blocking the guild because then python
doesn't do is that the idea that like in
local it's what's happening by by just
paralyzing across the processes
yeah i mean we're using all the cores in
the machine yeah
okay thank you
hi
does it require fine tuning to work
efficiently i mean
different data sizes requires different
settings like number of
partitions or
maybe data could be skewed
[Music]
great question so uh the desk scheduler
again is very smart and we'll do a lot
of optimizations for you uh so
definitely running it out of blocks uh
you know
dusk will do that for you um there is an
option to customize and you can play
around and see what that does uh for
sure to try and beat the scheduler we
could have a competition but uh yeah
no it's
the the idea is that dasc will
optimize that for you
but to give one one concrete example um
so so for example when we read in this
data set here at the top let's see
we didn't specify the number of
partitions
right
so dask
decided to make it 10.
you can play around with this so you can
re-partition and say okay i want you can
repartition based on partition size the
rule of thumb is to do about 100 mega
megabytes
um but if you are unhappy with how fast
it's running you can uh you can change
and see if that that has impact yeah
in your example you are showing
an array that's read in so you already
have the huge data set somewhere
uh what usually happens to me is that i
have two or even more moderate sized
data sets and then i have to cross
product them and then boom it uh it
tracks my memory can i do this with
let's say two pandas data frames and
cross product the index and then get out
of the
lazy evaluated dusk data frame that i
then can parallelize
my go-to would be to turn them into desk
arrays first
uh so that they are uh
lazy and then do that uh cross-product
operation on those yeah
so um
online someone asked is there a way to
run ducks on an existing
map r or spark cluster
on the spark cluster yeah
uh i know that my colleague gus is
working on a video to do to run dusk on
data bricks
uh so i assume it's possible i've never
done it myself
and i would i would avoid i mean the
great thing about dusk is that it's
python native right so you
don't have to deal with the jvm you
don't get weird scholar messages uh
error messages um so my advice would be
uh
to to to stay
in python um yeah
then finally um is there a kind of
playground for coit or maybe a demo
account
yeah so um
we
have a free tier it requires activation
uh because we had uh issues with crypto
miners uh the last couple of weeks uh
unfortunately um so we uh yeah you could
you can uh go to cloud.coil.io
um
yeah i'm already signed in so that won't
be very helpful but um
yeah you you uh if you go
yeah yeah so it's it's far from optimal
at the moment and we're very aware of
that and we're working hard to to
uh find a workaround but right now you
can sign up for an account uh and just
we we uh we have to confirm that you are
a human using it for uh
for for a good reason and we will uh we
will activate your account yeah
thanks
all right
uh let's see how are we doing on time
let's
um the next notebook doesn't have any
code you uh you can you can open it to
follow along but uh it's basically uh
just run through of some basic desk
concepts now that we've seen what it
does um
it's it's it's also kind of important to
have a basic understanding of
distributed computing and the
architecture of das to understand things
like how you can optimize performance
um so we've already seen right
das
follows syntax of of the pi data
ecosystem
and does that on purpose um and
basically what we've demonstrated so far
is is the desk array and the desk data
frame which are the kind of higher level
uh collections that that mimic pandas
and and numpy
and the lower we've seen one of the
lower level apis that's delayed uh all
of these collections built task graphs
as we've seen so we saw it specifically
with that's delayed that's data frame
also does it we just uh
it does that under the hood builds a
task graph that is executed by a desk
scheduler
there are technically four sketch desk
schedulers
but the distributed one is really the
one you should care about
unless you're doing experimentation on a
single machine and want to
look at things like the difference
between running on threads and processes
but the distributed one is is the one
that das will launch by default and this
is the one that will scale
seamlessly from your laptop to a cluster
as well
so some desk concepts
that will kind of help help you
understand what's going on
mentioned some of these already but this
is the basic architecture of a desk
cluster
and a das cluster can exist on your
local laptop
or in the cloud so you have a client
which is the user facing entry where
you're writing your python code in this
case the jupyter notebook
that communicates to a scheduler
which manages the state and sends tasks
to work workers for execution
and then the workers if you're working
locally will be the cores in your
machine
and if you're working remotely on the
cloud will usually be vms um
with with um yeah that will that will uh
do the actual work send it back to the
scheduler and then the scheduler will
send it back to the to the client
so when to use dusk we talked about this
a little bit already with joshua's
question uh but um let's see if this
fits in the screen like this
basically um
there's two axes that are imported here
one is data size the other is
computation time
so if your data size is manageable and
your computation time is you're happy
with that then you're in this lower left
quadrant it fits in your ram you're
happy with how long it takes don't use
ask
there's overhead it gets complex uh
don't bother
the other pi data libraries
will serve you best here
but if your data size starts to increase
beyond what you can load into ram
you start running into memory errors
that's one potential use case of desk
or if your computations are taking too
long and you want to use parallel
processing to speed that up that's
another use case or of course both
then uh definitely uh give dusk
a try
um and yeah we say this all the time
don't use the ask if you don't need to
uh pandas not by scikit-learn these are
great
we work closely with with with the
maintainers
of these libraries um and there's a
reason why they're popular
so don't don't use
das because the overhead may be larger
than the performance gain that you get
with that let's jump deeper into the das
data frame api some questions
um
can we can we keep them for a little
later sure thanks
um so this is we saw it uh in practice
uh a little bit already uh but let's
let's just dive a little uh deeper in so
we'll uh download the same flight data
import das dataframe and read it into a
dask data frame
you'll often see ddf when using dask
to distinguish it from df so df stands
for das data frame
and basically as i mentioned
dask will do sort of a pass over the
data to give you some schematic
information like the column names the
number of partitions and the data types
so these are things you can inspect
without calling compute these are loaded
into memory small schematic information
and you can get the data types
and as mentioned you can see the number
of partitions
now if you wanted to
re-partition this
you could oh
let's see partition size for example
we are activating coil accounts by the
way so we're doing requesting then you
can you'll get activated in a few
minutes my colleague is at the booth
with his laptop activating people
perfect thanks david
but i think it won't work from binder
they're blocking outgoing outreach to
certain most ports and so if you're
running a notebook in binder i don't
think you can you'll be able to watch
the cluster but not actually use it
okay thanks
right so um for the most part a das data
frame will look and feel like a pandas
data frame and that is because under the
hood
it is just a bunch of pandas data frames
so pandas works great we see no reason
to
kind of reinvent the wheel
but it has a scalability issue so what
das does is take your big data set cut
it up into chunks or partitions each
partition is a pandas data frame
and dask will orchestrate applying
pandas methods and operations onto those
uh pandas data frames in parallel and
bringing the results back uh
to the client
so yeah that i would say yeah anywhere
between 80 85 percent of of the the
pandas api is is supported by dusk uh
we're continuously working to increase
that um i don't think it'll ever be 100
because some things when running and
distributed just
get
get more complex
but like i said under the hood
a collection like das dataframe is
building task graphs
so this is
these are our 10 partitions each
partition is the result
of reading csv this is a relatively
simple task graph this is embarrassingly
parallel if you would have 10 cores this
could all happen at the same time
we've seen uh calling head
uh and yeah so this this calls compute
sort of uh implicitly under the hood
now um because
a dash data frame implements the pandas
api we can write familiar pandas code
using our das data frames
so you can call for example
something like max
on a specific column
again this won't give you the result
it'll only build the task graph to get
to the results so let's see if this will
work
this is starting to get a little bit
more interesting
we have our 10 partitions each one is
the result of reading a chunk of the
data from csv
getting the column
applying a max
function
getting that result and then applying a
max
over all of the 10 partitions to give
you your final result
right this is just kind of
you can use that data frames without
ever looking at these task graphs
i myself when i use that data firms
rarely look at them
but it's helpful for this tutorial to
kind of understand uh what what's
happening and how it's working
under the hood and also to see kind of
start spotting performance gains right
so if you
um
are yeah running four cores then uh four
of these can run in parallel um but ten
would be faster
eight or six might not necessarily be
faster because you'd still be waiting uh
in either case
uh you can use persist
which will persist uh the results to
cluster memory uh if so
um
yeah and that is basically caching so
this will if you're working locally
there's not really a difference because
your cluster is local but if you're
working in the cloud then you can uh or
another cluster you can persist them to
cluster memory
using
persist
and this will trigger computation uh
on
the cluster but your notebook can
continue working
so there's computations happening in the
background
and again here this all this has done so
far is built the task graph which is why
this is so fast
[Music]
but if we specifically run compute
then it will take a little bit longer
and it'll
give us
the result that we're looking for
um
cool
let's see
i see that i
left the code in the notebook okay the
idea was to turn these into exercises
but uh i think all the code is still in
there sorry about that um
uh yeah this is basically just showing
um more examples of of how
we can use pandas api but just add
compute at the end
so this should all be um very familiar
and to your point about persisting and
computing
so
in the examples and the exercises we saw
above we sometimes perform the same
operation more than once
uh that's dataframes hashes the
arguments allowing duplicate
complication computations to be shared
and you can use desk.compute to merge
task graphs of multiple operations
for example if we compute the mean and
the standard deviation for departure
delay of all non-cancelled flights
since task operations are lazy these
values aren't the final results until we
compute them they're just the recipe so
if we compute them with two calls to
compute there will be no sharing of
intermediate results
right this first cell nothing's
happening happening yet
if we call compute
twice this will take about three and a
half seconds
but if we share results by using das dot
compute to compute both of these at the
same time
this will be a lot faster that's about
half the time because the two task
graphs are merged and results can be
shared between the two task graphs
and we get even more interesting task
graphs here
i'm not going to walk through the whole
thing but you can see that results are
shared
here
and here and then all the way back here
and this is really i mean it's kind of
if we take the analogy of das as an
engine um
there's kind of two ways you can
approach an engine right some people
just want to get in the car and drive
um you can do that you never have to
look at a task graph to use dusk some
people like to get into the engine and
say hey i know porsche built this but i
think i'm better
and you can tweak it and we give you
that freedom
and that's that's really a great thing
about
sort of the flexibility of desk
mentioned already uh earlier but there's
a few different desk schedulers
but really the one to know when you get
started is the distributed uh it offers
the most features and diagnostics so the
dashboard that we saw earlier is
something that's only available in the
distributed scheduler
and this is also the scheduler that
allows you to scale seamlessly from
local to cluster
you can
instantiate a distributed scheduler on
your local machine
by
calling from distributed import client
and then
creating a client with in this case
eight workers is the maximum course that
i have on my machine if you don't
specify any workers it'll just use all
the cores
so you you can kind of
decide what you want
and creating that client object will
output a desk dashboard
[Music]
have to actually
execute
so
this is this is the dusk dashboard for
my local cluster
this is something if you're using coiled
we provide as part of our interface but
if you're just using das open source
this dashboard is available to you as
well
through this client hyperlink
uh let me pause here for a second for
questions
uh that depends a little bit on what you
on a few things are you running them
close together in time are they
separated far apart
yeah so if you if you
um
calculate the median and call compute
then then dusk is building the task
graph until you call compute it's it's
building a task graph and it will hash
all of your computations and and calls
and and and we'll will say okay this is
that value i've already calculated it
let me bring it over there
it will only run once if you call
compute it'll keep building the task
graph
does that answer your questions
absolutely yeah
yes yeah uh so dusk
geopanda specifically is a good question
i know spatialpand does an x-ray uh i
mean x-ray runs with dusk
um and geopandas i'd have to look
specifically but i know yeah that's
sports polygons as well
what happens
if i
use a high cardinality column to
distribute my algorithm
let's say i do
group by user id apply and there are
billions of users so how how does it
handle that so
i didn't hear the first few words of
your question sorry um what happens if i
choose a high cardinality column
um to um distribute um the algorithm or
or the function um
like like users so there are billions of
users and if i do
df group by user um sum or whatever um
there will be billions of um parallel
tasks right yeah so how does um dusk
handle
this yeah so it's possible that uh your
your your question i think underneath
that is if you call compute on that that
might cause a memory error
is that your is that your concern um no
my concern is i guess um the number of
tasks
produced so um yeah yeah i mean the
number of tasks shouldn't be a problem
uh it might take a while uh or if the
result is really large uh
it won't okay because in in spark um i
cannot do such thing i cannot um group
by um user um
i cannot do group by on high cardinality
columns
so but you're saying it's not a problem
with task right so i i don't see why not
no okay
uh hey
does das have support for asynchronous
computation
uh
yes what specifically would you want to
use it for
uh just in general the compute function
that uh computes the final value yes
asynchronous uh so um and with
asynchronous you mean you can launch it
and and keep working exactly yeah so
that's what something what that persist
uh does
uh
that persists and and then there's also
the das futures api
uh which which is asynchronous
online questions should i exit now sorry
okay um so the first one is um is dax
root csv also faster on local machine or
does it require distributed storage such
as s3 to profit from speed up at reading
data in
uh no it doesn't require uh cloud
storage to be faster
i've like we mentioned earlier if your
data set fits uh in a pandas data frame
you might be better off with windows if
i run dax on my local machine
is it
the optimal scheduler choosing
automatically or do i have to set it
manually is the optimal what is the
optimal scheduler chosen automatically
or do i have to set it manually yeah so
it will go um
yeah but i mean you should use the the
the distributed scheduler when you're
starting out which
you do with
with this code
so what is the best strategy for data
location or assets on cluster all
workers should have access to the data
what is the best strategy for data
location um
i'm not sure i understand that question
okay yeah maybe the um
the person that asks it will rephrase so
um how would you use dax for many
different rogues function
or assessing the same text column
sorry one more time
how would you use dax for
using many different regrex function
or assessing the same text column
interesting okay uh
the question is how you would use desk
to apply many different rejects
functions
so dask
allows you to parallelize any python
function so that should include reject
functions
you can map them
across
yeah it depends if it's in a data frame
you can do something called map
partitions
which will map any function
across all of the
partitions and if you remember each
partition is a pandas data frame so any
function that can run on the pandas data
frame can be mapped using the map
partitions api okay
could you briefly go over the difference
between dax data frames and dax bags
are there any specific use cases to use
one versus another yeah uh so we haven't
really looked at desk bags yet um
desk bags is an api that is
uh yeah uses bags there's a mathematical
concept unstructured uh unordered uh
list
um
that i've mostly seen used for uh
like json type data
so things that don't fit neatly in a
tabular format
you would use dash bags
should you repartition your
should you repartition after subsetting
your data
report
yeah uh depends it can be smart to do
um
yeah then we can get
kind of get into the nitty-gritty of of
specific use case uh so dusk optimizes a
lot uh if you are
subsetting uh it is possible that you
end up with still let's say 100
partitions but each of these partitions
only has two megabytes of data
then it would be smart to re-partition
yeah serious more questions uh yeah a
lot more or
like five more okay let's let's take a
break and uh do some more later okay
yeah thanks
all right
um
so that was um our dive into das data
frames we'll go to the next notebook
which goes into parallel and distributed
machine learning with desk
um
just a hands up again people experience
with scikit-learn
okay so it's quite a big group so i
think i will
run through the first part of this quite
quickly
so yeah dask
ml is the library that scales
scikit-learn algorithms using the same
syntax
and
this is
a different version of the
okay it's not
there we go
the diagram we saw earlier but
specifically for machine learning um
again you might be memory bound or
compute bound uh in your in your scaling
issues with machine learning so you
might have a data set that's too large
or you have a data set that fits into
ram but your model size is too large
for example because you're running a
very heavy grid search
and you want to
speed that up
to meet
your project deadline
um
so this is a quick refresh of
scikit-learn i'm going to run through
this very quickly because it seems like
most people are familiar um but
basically um
we have the scikit-learn api
which accepts um
samples matrix and puts target values
we can fit a support vector classifier
basically the you know the very familiar
fit and and train api that that
scikit-learn is famous for
um
we can do a grid search cv uh
over a number of parameters
in this case doing eight fits
and get the best parameters and the best
score
out of that grid search
so if you're compute bound
and you want to speed up something like
this so let's actually
run these
quickly
this will you'll see each fit coming up
sequentially
that's fine if you're doing eight
relatively small amount of data each one
takes a bit of time
and
it's done in about 17 seconds
now imagine this was a either a much
larger data set
or you were doing a grid search over
many different
parameters
you can speed this up with job lib using
single machine parallelism
so
this you don't need to ask for yet this
is a feature that's part of scikit-learn
any algorithm that has the end jobs
keyword argument can be run in
parallel so here we're running the same
grid search but saying n jobs equals to
-1 this will make use of all of the
cores in your machine
we no longer get a sequential list of
fits because they're being
fitted in parallel
but this runs about 10 seconds faster
now if this is still not enough for you
you want this to run in two seconds or
it's actually running for 30 minutes and
you want it to be five minutes
you can scale this up further with dusk
so uh dasc and joblib maintainers work
together
to connect
the job lib
parallelism and to multi-machine
so
you would
spin up or you would launch a desk
scheduler
like we did before
specify
your parameters
because here we're running a lot more
and
you would say with job create a context
manager uh job lib parallel back end
specify desk
and then
run this
oh
run this in parallel
so this is doing 72 fits
and who can spot where i'm cheating at
the moment
trying to keep you all sharp i know it's
early in the morning still
so this is actually still just running
on my machine
so
actually this is no different than
joblib
this would become different if i would
spin up
a coiled cluster here
which i could
which i have running so we could
say let's see it'd be fun to test this
in person
live so this is just took
28 seconds
if i
let's see
import coiled
cluster
cluster should still be running
i can reference it with this name
and say okay i want to connect from this
ipython session i want to connect to
this running cluster
and then instead of saying n workers
which creates a local cluster on my
machine i say okay desk connect to this
remote cluster
and again right now with the same code
we'll be running this in the cloud on a
cluster with
20 workers
let's see how long it takes
speed up um
of about 10 seconds in this case
so and the specific speed up you know
you can you we can talk for for a long
time about how to optimize this but
basically what it i wanted to
demonstrate here is the dash code stays
the same uh you just switch out the
cluster object uh to be to work either
locally or in the cloud
any questions about this
actually you didn't use any task
function here at all so it was basically
pure psychic learn code with just this
context manager
and that was it yeah so this is a
collaboration between job lib and ask
where you can specify
uh a back end to job lib uh to be desk
and then
your code will know okay this i need to
use das dask has been connected to this
cluster
but in this case you're not running any
das
syntax okay that's awesome thanks
uh hi
just one question how does it perform
with more clients
so if you have in such cluster how many
concurrent clients can you support
how many uh
so clients at the same time yeah exactly
so like people running that exact same
script at the same time
um on the same cluster yeah
yeah that should be possible so multiple
people can connect to a coiled cluster
um you'll be competing for resources
obviously so um
is there is there a way to kind of
reserve workers like available workers
so that you don't use all of them for a
single request uh that's a good question
i personally don't know the answer to
that maybe
david does
but you might do that
okay thanks thanks
so you just
showed how to use for example
job lib with parallelization and then
after that
you showed the same thing in dashboard
on the same machine in this case you
wouldn't have any uh speed up compared
to pure job blip
correctly and when i have like a a
really big machine with like 100 cores
and i don't know like hundreds of
gigabytes of ram
would a
cluster consisting of
various nodes would still be
faster than this single machine
depends on your machine depends on the
cluster
if the cluster is you know as as uh
double the amount of cores then yeah
that definitely will be faster if you
have access
let's say we have like the same amount
of cores in the cluster and on the
single machine for example uh then i
would recommend staying on the single
machine
okay yeah but still using um dust or
no need in that case if you can scale
so this is specifically for compute
bound machine learning problems if you
can stay on a single machine and you
have access to a large one
and you're happy with the results stay
on the single machine and you just use
job lib yeah all right thanks
okay
now the second
type of problem scaling problem that you
might have
with machine learning is memory bound so
this is where your data set is too large
to
process on the machine that you're
working on
this is where you would use the das ml
library
and
das ml has estimators that work well on
dask arrays and task data frames
so if you remember from what we've
talked about previously das data frame
cuts up your big data into smaller
partitions
and das ml
has estimators that that are optimized
to work on those
partitioned data frames
so in this case um
again you'll you'll see this this mimics
the the scikit-learn api so we import
make regression and linear regression to
create some synthetic data
um
this is just for demonstrative purposes
so actually you know seven megabytes
shouldn't be using a task array for this
but just to to illustrate what it can do
instantiate the linear regression
model
fit it
and then
predict so and this is
again still running on our coiled
cluster in the cloud
so yeah this should all look very
familiar uh as i mentioned earlier um
not all algorithms can be run in
parallel uh so something like random
forest is great um other things uh are
not possible to to parallelize
so there's there's a limited set of of
algorithms that are available in in das
ml
um
this section i've already uh
illustrated by by showing how you
connect to a coiled cluster but yeah
sure functions are only implemented by
dusk specifically that's like a linear
regression of these songwrappers of
trichildren it's a it's a
if i'm not mistaken it's a parallel
implementation uh written by the dascaml
ten minutes okay wow okay go fast
we have 10 minutes left
so i'm gonna
let me see yeah i think i i illustrated
the basics of this uh
notebook here
um so i think i'll open it up for
questions since we have 10 minutes uh if
there's anything specifically
you would like me to dive into deeper we
can take some questions online as well
for the people at home
okay so maybe um the most voted
questions
or to start with the most voted
questions
so the communication backend of dax
seems to be using tcp
tls
are you also planning to support
infiniband as well in the future
i can't answer that question
is that something
not aware okay
okay um
then um
where is
okay where is the training data which
might be huge
is it uploaded to the cluster
or could that be a bottleneck
yeah so um
the date should not be loaded into the
cluster memory at one point unless you
specifically tell dusk to do that
no so i mean that's the whole point of
task right it will cut up your data set
into partitions and process those
on the fly yeah so what if i run that
data frame on
a htc cluster
will it then uncomfortably take
as many calls as possible
available yeah
um
i'm
quite certain you can specify that i
don't
i mostly uh run coil sorry run desk in
the cloud i know we have uh plenty of
people running it on hpc uh so there's
there's a bunch of um uh sort of open
source libraries um like desk
cloud providers for the cloud class
gateway uh yarn
uh that will will give you the the
options you need to to to use an hpc
cluster that's quite a common use case
we see especially in academia
so when i make a dax distributed
scheduler on a compute node
on a slum cluster
i cannot use the dashboard link are
there alternatives for deeper insights
are there sorry are there what for
deeper insights alternatives for deeper
insights you can't use the dashboard
interesting
uh
yeah i need to know more about the
specific setup because there are
there are ways to get that dashboard
link
differently um
yeah
tell them to reach out to me on linkedin
i'd like to talk to them yeah
yeah i guess
so would there ever be a situation where
number of tags would not match number of
partitions
i'm asking because boots are mentioned
in the output every time
the number of tasks will not match the
number of partitions yeah
i'm not sure what that means
so
where can i find more extensive
documentation for example for dax job
queue
html condo and slam
than on the website documentation
uh the the documentation that exists is
is uh you can find through the desk.org
website and the dusk discourse
um so that's maybe a good place
to go now
the discourse is a great place uh to ask
a lot of questions that i wasn't able to
answer today
and and any other so this is where um
at coiled we we employ quite a few uh
dusk
open source engineers and we're
constantly monitoring uh the das
discourse channel so if there's i mean
you know working in distributed
computing and
it gets complicated quick um so so ask
ask your questions and and uh respond
very quickly here so does dax support
delta lake storage format
delta lake store we
uh highly recommend working with parquet
and dusk works very well with parquet
okay
yeah i don't know if anybody have any
questions here
yeah so maybe i'll wrap it up with a few
more slides here
so
uh after this tutorial um
there's a lot more to learn so hopefully
this gave you kind of the the
the basics uh to try dask out if you
haven't tried it before um if you have
more questions come find us at the booth
the opposite the
cafeteria area
we also have a
blog with lots of
more resources for specific use cases or
best practices for using desk
and some great webinars for for uh
practical use cases
um
i'll leave a few links up here for
specific use cases so desk and machine
learning we talked about scikit-learn
in the tutorial what i did not get to
right now is the xg boost integration
with dusk
so xgboost has a native kind of
integration just like joblib where you
can say okay run this on das
and without running any desk code
you can run your extra trainer actually
boost model in parallel so there's
an example here that trains on 100
gigabytes in four minutes
you can also use it with pytorch
dusk integrates well with
many workflow orchestration tools
and if you
are really kind of want to get down to
the nitty-gritty of how the engine works
and want to tweak that there's some sort
of advanced
best practices topics
here
um at coiled we provide task training so
if this is something you're interested
in learning uh for example for your
organization
um we provide a
four half day training um it's given by
adam brindle highly recommended the
curriculum is
here and
for python we have a 50
discount
coupon
so
reach out to us if that sounds
interesting you can also meet us at the
booth we can tell you more about how it
works
and i showed this already but these are
the places where you can find us so das
discourse is the place to ask any desk
questions if you're interested in coiled
come talk to me
david guido or gus uh we're at the
coiled
stand upstairs
and um yeah i hope this was helpful
can you take a few more questions a few
more questions sure yeah so um
can you share jupiter notebook
which one
no i like
the question
can i share the jupiter notebooks yes uh
yeah so the the notebooks are in the
github repo so if you
[Music]
go to this link uh the notebooks are all
there so
who is
distributing data to workers do do they
read data like
read csv or should they have read access
to data or is it the tax of scheduler
uh so the workers will all have access
to the data yeah okay
okay so i think the rest of the
questions okay
any more questions for the room before
we end okay
okay
you get an applause for your question
that's all right thank you very much for
that
why would i want to use dusk with
pytorch
why yes to parallelize
but uh python also has a parallel cpu
and gpu and also has distributed
training
um
i'm not sure why would i want uh
what would uh using dusk uh what
advantages would can you easily scale to
a cloud uh cluster with pytorch natively
well we are distributing training there
sorry we have distributed training on
multiple machines we also use that we
could also use cloud machines for uh
distributed training okay
um
[Music]
yeah let's let's talk after uh i'm
curious yeah thank you not familiar
okay thanks
[Applause]